um so just to introduce myself my name
is Joyce I'm a developer advocate at
postman and I can't quite see you guys
but how many people have heard of
postman ok I see almost everyone which
is great Thank You Canada
um so postman okay I'm gonna be
progressing my slides
okay so postman huge user base lots and
lots of people using it lots of
companies and part of my job a very
small part of my job is actually talking
at conferences like these but a bigger
part of my job is talking face-to-face
one-on-one with teams and so I get to
find out the hottest stuff that's going
on stuff that people are struggling with
and one of the biggest challenges that
teams are facing right now is moving to
the cloud so using cloud services
spinning stuff up on cloud
infrastructure micro services
working with containers all of this
stuff is made possible by api's but the
more cloud hybrid usage you're adopting
the more exponentially your complexity
is increasing so it gets really
complicated let's take an example of a
simple application stack let's just say
you have a front-end a back-end and
maybe you have a data store maybe you
don't very simple now let's compare this
simple stack to a microservice a stack
whoa okay so you have a couple different
clients maybe have a web client mobile
IOT you're accessing your services
through an API gateway and you probably
have a bunch of data stores a bunch of
services talking to each other maybe you
have some third party API integrations
so compared to a monolithic architecture
this baby baby monolith here the
complexity of working in micro services
increases exponentially so today
services they're everywhere and apps are
having these elaborate conversations
with each other a few years ago I
remember talking to people and there
were whole teams refusing to move to
anything cloud
these are FinTech these are you know
Europe going through GDP are health tech
and nowadays it's really hard to find
somebody that's not using cloud services
if you're on AWS as
GCP yeah that's a cloud so the API first
approach is what I'm gonna talk about
today the name of this talk is standing
on the shoulders of api's we'll talk
about what is an API first approach what
does it look like in modern
organizations I'll share some of those
stories and what tools support this
approach all right first up what is an
API first approach so let's think about
an old cliche form follows function
we've all heard of this question for the
crowd what do you think this is and I'm
looking for people to yell stuff out
okay I heard Spyder first but juicer so
maybe we have a designer in our midst so
yes yes this is an orange juicer as
evidenced by maybe this citrus in this
glass of juice so when you guys were
looking at that first picture on the
left you're thinking I'm looking at the
outside appearance like what could it
possibly be used for you're looking at
the form and you're speculating about
the function now what if I say excuse me
sir I love me some Sunday morning
mimosas could you please make me a
juicer what's it gonna look like this
thing what if I asked you you know what
I actually have a restaurant and I need
to make a lot of orange juice what's
that gonna look like probably not this
thing or what if you have international
distribution for orange juice and you
need to make a ginormous juicer so the
point is that the form of the juicer is
going to be very dependent very
different depending on what I say the
function should be so this is form
follows function
we know this the quote was actually from
the late 1800s though Louis Sullivan he
was an architect he was talking about
designing buildings or physical things
so the physical design of things form
follows function makes a lot of sense so
the form is the outside surface it's
what users interact with and the
function determines the form so for
physical objects it makes sense now when
you're talking about developing software
we need to back up even more so API
first development means surprise
developing the actual API first
so when you add a new feature or you
update new functionality the
functionality is first going to be
exposed as an API and then developers
are going to build out the rest of that
application from that interface they're
gonna be the first consumers of your API
so that's API first development and when
you talk about API first design you're
taking another step for it a little bit
earlier so plan the functionality before
you actually build out the interface
much less the rest of the app choice
what do you mean plan of course I plan
stuff before I build it so what
functionality will be API have what data
will it expose what will the developer
experience be like how many of us think
about that when we're building out an
API and how will it scale when we want
to expand to other clients devices or
platforms how are we gonna scale that up
okay so we'll come back to this design
phase of developing an API but the
purpose of planning your API upfront is
to future-proof your API so that you can
you can harden yourself against other
consumers other clients so once you
design and you develop your API now your
app developers can can consume it in
other apps that require this
functionality can consume it too
independently so no matter what you're
doing web developer mobile developer
other app developers can consume this
functionality independently and to be
fair we have a lot of white space on the
left there your new API probably wasn't
the very first API ever born
your new API is likely consuming other
existing api's and that's the circle of
life
so API first it's a software development
pattern that asks you to design or scope
out your api's before you build the
software okay let's compare this with
something that we all know and love code
first this is the traditional code first
approach when you have this type of code
force approach you might start off in
your IDE okay you're sitting in front of
your favorite IDE you're typing out a
few lines of code somewhere in the back
of my mind you know eventually I'm
needed build out an interface or maybe I
pass it off to somebody else and they
build out the interface but you know
what your phone
to sing on core functionality and
eventually somebody else will figure out
the interface when it comes time to
figure out that interface that API the
core service has already baked so now
it's the functionality of that service
that's driving what that interface looks
like and it's not necessarily what your
consumers need so you've seen this
before where the API is essentially
shoehorned in after the core
functionality is built out and you can't
maybe retrieve the data that you want
because access is granted a certain way
or the data model is structured a
certain way so once you write your code
you make your commits you push it to a
repo and you deploy it now thank you
very much for deploying this API now
you're independent teams can start
consuming it so you have to wait until
the last minute
before your testers can test your
writers can write and even stakeholders
can weigh in on oh I actually didn't
want it back can you change it to this
so this waiting around is no good but
that's code first now let's compare this
with an API first approach so instead of
starting with code you start with the
design and actually maybe you even start
with tests test-driven development maybe
you start with mocks the mock is gonna
be a prototype of what you want to
demonstrate the future functionality of
your API to be maybe you start with
documentation and you might see where
this is going
so with an API first approach you can
actually do agile development or even if
you don't identify with an agile shop if
you have any kind of rapid iteration
this allows you to wrap rapidly iterate
because you're getting feedback earlier
in the process and now you can get more
feedback more often all right so once
everyone agrees on the direction of your
API this design then becomes a contract
that everyone can begin building against
so now your testers come in your
documentary nor your writers come in and
your duds come in and everyone can start
working in parallel so yes it takes a
little bit more time up front to do
orange box but it cuts down on the
overall development time from tip to
tail
and in a world where systems are talking
to each other all the time
design your api's before you implement
them this will save you time in the long
run over the course of the entire
development lifecycle all right but what
if I don't wanna what if I don't want to
delay my development I want to get
started right now is it worth it why
would I even take this extra time so you
know what API first might not be for you
if you're just you have that simple
stack front-end back-end maybe datastore
maybe you're a startup that I need to
get my proof-of-concept out today
otherwise somebody else is gonna eat my
lunch but if you're a little bit more of
a mature organization and you're
thinking about the future why would you
take the extra time so spending time to
design your API gives you earlier
validation so getting that feedback
early and often allows you to adapt to
any new information ah new insight did
not know that or oh our competitors
actually did something really cool last
week let's change our design and our
implementation and this reduces the
overall cost of your development because
you catch your bugs earlier all right
taking extra time to design your API
gives you a clear abstraction layer if
you show only what's absolutely
necessary to anybody that's going to be
consuming your API you have a clear
separation of concerns and in fact
everyone else can ramp up a lot quicker
because you don't have to worry about
what's inside here taking extra time to
design your API allows you to decouple
your dependencies this is what I was
talking about earlier once you have a
contract you don't have to keep thinking
back and saying oh how should we handle
this you already have an explicit
contract your work can progress
independently of whatever anyone else is
doing on your team taking extra time to
design your API lets you have faster
growth so focusing on the design makes
you think about future functionality not
endlessly but at least give it some
thought and then you can scale to other
apps devices and platforms
lastly taking extra time to design your
API gives you freedom from constraints
if you're an architect if you're
architecting this API now you're
constrained only by the data model in
the business logic you don't have to
worry about any legacy constraints
alright there's a bunch of reasons why I
just went through them all why taking a
little bit of extra time at the very
beginning of the development lifecycle
will save you more time in long run
alright so in a nutshell code first you
have jobs like testing documentation
providing feedback all of that you have
to wait for development to finish first
so that's a synchronous flow and it's
what's used in traditional waterfall
development that's fine but if you want
to work a little bit faster with API
first you decouple your dependency so
you can work in parallel and then
testing documentation even providing
feedback can get started at the same
time right away and it allows you to be
a little bit more agile so I'm gonna end
this section with the relevant xkcd all
right I'm gonna read this because I'm
guessing the people said over there
before so this is a change log changes
in version 1017 the CP oh no longer
overheats when you hold down spacebar
comments longtime user for writes in
this update broke my workflow my control
key is harder each so I hold spacebar
instead and I configured Emacs to
interpret rapid temperature rise as
control admin replies that's horrifying
longtime user for writes look my setup
works for me just add an option to
re-enable spacebar heating an xkcd x'
caption is every change break someone's
workflow so this little vignette here we
understand but somebody much smarter
came up with this with large-scale
systems it's hard to separate the
interface from your implementation does
anybody know who the smarty was I'm
gonna yell it out give you t-shirt
oh maybe I'll give you t-shirt anyways
so who came up with this
besides xkcd is Hyrum right so Hyrum law
says with a sufficient number of users
of an API it doesn't matter what you
promised in the contract all observable
behaviors in your system even if you
didn't intend it will be dependent on by
somebody so it doesn't matter what you
explicitly document any changes to an
implementation will violate your users
expectations TLDR xkcd said every change
break someone's workflow okay so now we
know what API first means and some of
the benefits let's take a look at what
does API first look like in modern orgs
so first
are there any API first companies yes
the answer is yes
so there's companies like algo liya algo
leah has search as a service Twilio
everyone knows Twilio its communications
as a service their API only companies
not even just API first their API only
there's no real front-end to speak of
with these companies they offer their
services through an API you consume them
via API so postman CTO on Kitsap D
actually calls this API is a product
this is not a real thing please don't
start saying it but if you wanted to it
would be hashtag app ok API is a product
and I don't know if you can read this
tweet here but he said treating an API
as a product requires the API design to
proceed code and to focus on developer
experience even for private api's not to
mention public api's private api's so
one well-known example of such a company
is as we mentioned before Twilio so Ron
Huddle's that's oppose me Ron Ron
Huddleston of Twilio said Twilio is
unique API first cloud platform is
tailor-made to support an ecosystem of
partners that are differentiated by the
innovations they deliver for their
customers so it's an API first
communications platform not only do they
offer their services to paying customers
via API their teams are actually
structured in a way that really reflects
the api's so their teams are
independently constructed so that they
communicate independently just like
api's so Twilio started started off back
in the day not even that long ago but
started off as an API first company but
not everyone is so lucky so Stephenie
Shermer of Etsy has famously talked
about this all of the code that was
built for the website then had to be
rebuilt in our API to be used by our iOS
and Android apps
oh when Etsy first came about they
developed their code base who knew that
there would be mobile apps well now we
got to redo it so Etsy famously switched
to an API approach after they had to
implement all of their code and logic
twice and perhaps one of the most famous
API first companies is hey whoa who's on
my slides so Ben Christensen of Netflix
said a ton of stuff about API first I
won't read up at all but they're another
company that organizes their engineering
teams similar to Twilio with independent
api's they know that this is how their
teams communicate
let's decouple everything so that one
team is not blocking another team okay
so we started this section off by
talking about API as a product hashtag
app awesome thank you okay so even if
you're not a Twilio or Netflix a lot of
engineering teams today have a separate
group an API group they treat it as a
product or a separate platform or we
actually have API engineers right
somebody who's specialized function is
to build new api's and maintain how they
scale all right so we can't talk about
API first without also talking about
tools and workflow so postman is a
developer tool and I will show you a
little bit about postman but I'm not
gonna focus too much on that overall so
let's just get a little bit tactical so
what tools support API first
all right I'm gonna start off with a
basic question that should have been
asked at the beginning of this talk what
is an API that's always my first answer
what else do you say to your friends
that are like what do you do website for
websites I haven't heard that data
everyone's afraid to say something else
besides application programming
interface I get it I get it okay so what
is an API when you're talking about API
is sometimes you're talking about the
interface right
it has the word interface in there it's
the actual interface that I'm using to
potentially do something else
sometimes they're talking about the
implementation they're talking about the
code behind the interface
what is the logic that is what is the
value that's being delivered here and
sometimes they're talking about the
instance so an API or code is nothing
unless you deploy it and it's hosted
somewhere and it's actually serving the
value so let's start off by talking
about well steps on this one sorry
talking about roles okay when you're
talking about api's you have producer
who builds and serves an API and you
have a consumer who uses that API for
whatever it is that they're doing these
producers and consumers work across a
variety of scopes and you have private
scopes so you have private API is like
for internal microservices or just
internal stuff that you're serving up
you have partner API so say you're
working with the client and you have it
under lock and key but you're providing
services to a client and you have public
api's like github x' public api so you
can do stuff with their service and as
you progress across these scopes the
number of potential consumers increases
and to represent your API a provider
will use I didn't think huh
I didn't think anyone would guess this
but to represent your API providers use
a schema how many people use a schema
this is actually really interesting to
me one six okay that's not unusual
actually so schemas are still kind of
new and it's at the very very large
companies that have a ton of api is that
they're like oh god guys we got to do
something to keep this all in check so a
schema is a representation or a model of
your API some of these look familiar
though okay open API of those six people
with your hands up anybody is open API
swagger yup v1 v2 v3 three people this
is like this is how I do my research so
that I could get my next talk because
everyone's talking about open API but
how many people are actually using it
today graph QL anybody using graph QL
schema Wow more so ten people I see all
right I'm not gonna go through all of
these how many people use postman
collections well like ten maybe twelve
okay yes so I don't have a slide that
shows you the usage worldwide but I
can't tell you that postman these are
not mutually exclusive by the way you
might be using postman collections for
something totally different you might be
using it for documentation reference
development you might be using open API
for driving your specification for
driving your development or for on the
tail end for documenting it so these are
not mutually exclusive but worldwide
postman collections is just a very
widely used format just because it's got
such a large user base and then back in
the day the ramela's Dahl API blueprint
all of those were you know you know had
their heyday heyday today open API v2 v2
not quite v3 adoption is there yet but
open API is probably the biggest winner
when it comes to specification format in
graph QL - like a lot of people aren't
using graph QL schema but they might be
using graph QL in general all right okay
so there's a bunch of different options
but in a nutshell if you just lost
consciousness for the last 20 minutes
API first TL DR this is API first design
not rocket science agree on your domain
boundaries in your data models before
you implement them so it enables a
provider to know what a potential
consumer is expecting and once you've
decided on an API first approach there's
a month's a bunch of questions to ask
producers how are we going to be
gathering these requirements how do we
share this API dot how do we share these
API Doc's how are we gonna collect
feedback a lot of process questions from
the consumer as well and for an
effective design you'll need to decide
on the process for designing documenting
and collaborating so that previous
schema slide I had up what schema
specification format are you gonna use
how will you use it because a schema is
subjective how you interpret it and how
you use it is subjective I've seen every
which way of people using open API v2
how will you document your API
internally and also externally are you
generate auto-generating documentation
are using an internal developer portal
that's gated and what will you use for
collaboration will you use a Google Doc
for collaboration we use more
sophisticated tools slack will you use
mocks so we talked about mocks for
parallel development being able to
explicitly say this is how I visualize
and propose my service to behave and
some people are using API contracts so
contracts you have consumer-driven
contract tests are very helpful when
you're talking about internal
microservices it's an explicit contract
that says this is how I expect provider
your service to behave and if it doesn't
behave like that you're gonna stomp on
my code all right let's walk through a
quick example so what does API first
look like using only postman this
section is gonna be a little bit short
I'm not going deep in a postman because
not everyone uses postman for everything
I don't know why not but you know come
talk to me afterwards if you have
questions about postman so what does API
first look like in postman
so you start off by designing the API so
collections so it doesn't people use
collections not everyone uses uses them
but it's a way to persist your data so
that the next time you come into postmen
you can see the same thing and save your
work it's a way to collaborate with your
teammates to demonstrate and point to
hey this is what I wanted to do and so
in this example that we're looking at
here you can see a collection on the
Left sidebar they're called push ups I'm
gonna build a it's called push up
sorry singular I'm gonna build an API
service called push up and I'm just
gonna do crud for push ups I'm gonna
create I'm gonna post create a new push
up get my push ups get all my push ups
update delete just basic crud and so
this is the service I'm proposing that I
want to build it looks like an API
reference but I'm proposing a new
service then I'm gonna save examples so
a lot of other schema formats you're
pairing of requests in responses I
proposed and I'm describing what a
typical response should look like this
will give me insight into the data model
and now I see all the different types of
responses that might be associated with
this request once you have an initial
draft I have my proposal for the new
service I want to build now I'm gonna go
ahead and get some feedback so there's a
ton of ways to get feedback and
collaborate and post me on but this
screenshot is showing you I made a joke
about Google Docs earlier but I think
it's a really good analogy that a lot of
people get when you're in a Google Doc
and somebody else is making a change
you're like hi Andy I can see you that
kind of thing so it is real-time
collaboration and when you share a
collection in postman with your team
members they can the default is that
they can read it right that's great they
can read it but if you want them to
collaborate on it then you just give
them edit capabilities so it is like a
Google Doc but for your AP is and now
I'm getting feedback and now my boss
says Joyce this is stupid why'd you make
a push ups API like what if in the
future we want to do something else
besides push ups well I want to do
squats and then somebody else is like I
want to do light stretching
okay so now you can make these changes
before you've actually touched touched a
lick of code you haven't even opened up
your IDE yet another way to get feedback
is with like a lightweight version
control so what I'm showing you here is
this little flyout and it's like oh it's
just me I'm the only one working on it
right now but it allows you to see all
the create update delete activities that
are happening with my proposed service
and if I want to I can roll it back Oh
totally didn't mean to call it Fitness I
want to call it workout and roll it back
to a certain point in time and then
there's also a more robust version
control we just looked at lightweight
version control where it's like roll
back but there is more robust version
control where if where you're explicitly
tagging versions of your API or tagging
versions of your collection to separate
things and you can fork and merge just
like just like it then you can leave
threaded comments wow this is like a
Google Doc okay so you can leave
threaded comments where you're like I
don't think this endpoint should behave
like this and then follow the thread
that way and then once you've hashed out
the details are basically negotiating so
I'm the provider trying to provide push
ups or fitness API and then York you are
my consumers that are telling me why
it's not a good idea or how I should add
this or rename this once we've
negotiated that and agreed then this
collection becomes specification for our
API and I'm guessing I have I have a bet
with myself how many people have used
mocks in postman and I win the bet with
myself okay so if you want to host your
endpoint fake host your endpoint on
postman cloud it's a real endpoint but
its fake because you didn't deploy
anything you can use postman mocks and
that's actually what the postman
engineering team does once they come up
with a contract then they spin up mock
servers and then provider and consumer
provider starts building out against
that spec and then consumer starts
writing their contractor event consumer
different contract tests against that so
we actually postman engineering uses
mocks for parallel development and
you're able to visualize the intended
behavior say your boss doesn't
have an IDE they don't have postman you
know how are they going to see your
proposed service they can then plug it
in and hit a mock endpoint in C
visualize the intended behavior all
right now it's time to build the API wow
that was like six seven slides before we
even looked at anything that remotely
resembled code so in postman I have
another bet with myself how many people
have generated code snippets - wow you
guys Oh web dev like no this this is
actually really powerful but if you're
getting something to work in postman and
you want to plop it into your app you
just generate a code snippet in whatever
framework what framework did I choose
node this is node code right
copy/paste plop it into your ID all
right so this is what API first can look
like in postman using only postman but
likely you're not like in a box and
you're like I can only use postman
rocking back and forth no most likely
you have tools that you're already using
and mix in a match depending on what
your what you're looking for and what
your work flow is will will do all right
okay final thoughts don't worry I have a
lot of final thoughts all right so
before we conclude what could possibly
go wrong what are some common API first
pitfalls so focusing on the design of
your API and future proofing your
service doesn't mean endlessly going
through all the what-if scenarios right
yes a solid design is going to have the
flexibility to adapt to new information
new insights but don't endlessly
ruminate and it's really hard especially
at scale to separate the interface and
the implementation do you remember he
said that the real smarty no not me
hyrum Hiram's law and xkcd it's really
hard to fully separate implementation
and interface especially in large-scale
systems because every
is gonna break someone's workflow even
if it wasn't intended to and lastly API
first is actually not natural for most
developers most developers when I asked
them to create a new service they're
gonna pull out their IDE and they're
gonna start tapping out a few lines of
code so you should expect some friction
so if you're a brand new team and you
didn't even have a code first process in
place you know maybe it's gonna be
easier but it's just not natural for a
lot of developers to think and work in
an API first way and as Kim Lane said it
can lay in our API evangelist he said it
very bluntly it's gonna be hard it's not
second nature in general for devs and
especially for developers that are used
to working code first okay so can you
remind me again why we're doing this
why is API first the correct approach
the preached approach for most software
development so API api's are a core part
of an organization's infrastructure and
as Tammi butoh said it api's are a
first-class citizen not everyone treats
api's as a first-class citizen
especially if you're just cobbling on
something after the fact Tami said when
a company measures their critical
services api's are considered
second-class citizens but api's are core
to a Nords infrastructure and not
understanding their weaknesses can lead
to performance issues and downtime so
Tami butoh principle sight reliable
reliability engineer and gremlin
gremlins relatively new chaos
engineering company when they created
their new company it was a bunch of
people like Tami's from Dropbox they had
people from Netflix they knew their [ __ ]
oh sorry
when they were building out their
company they built a pee first they
didn't even build an app they didn't
build a way for people for lay people to
interact with it they went API first
alright and if there's one benefit you
remember from that long list of benefits
that I said earlier earlier validation
even though you take a little bit of
extra time at the very beginning of your
development process over the course of
the entire project you're gonna save
a lot of time and headaches and as Phil
sturgeon said it he's British stop
building nonsense nobody wants and get
feedback early through mocks and docks
he said once you agree on a
specification you can keep using that
same contract for everything instead of
repeating yourself over and over again
and trying to keep everything in sync
okay so that was a 40 minute talk but
there's entire books written about API
first development if you work with api's
which I'm guessing everyone here does
this is really good resource so
continuous API management is an oldie
but goodie I actually don't know how old
it is but it's a goodie
and I would say 40% the first 40% of
this book is gold read it
the last 60% you can just keep it for
reference and then a couple other
resources so I worked at postman we have
a better practices medium
it's our technical blog we write about a
lot of stuff there that because we just
are so lucky to have so many users and
we get to talk to these users all the
time and share some of that more broadly
with the community Phil sturgeon owns
the group api's you won't hate Tammy
butoh site sre or principal s re at
gremlin and kin Lane API celebrity API
evangelist so that's all I have for you
today
what do you normally do questions I
can't see anything I see a hand back
there